doy digs in on the draw and wins it Garn cro
back to jordano and lilligren sends that off
Target jordano tries to seal the wall helps keep
it in Doby scores a shot from distance not sure if
it was redirected but the leaps have broken the
ice so many times you get great scoring chances
well this is just a turn and jump the puck towards
the net what the officials were talking about was
there did home touch that one or not if anything
it went off the middle of his shaft didn't look
high but that's one of those knucklers that
just finds its way through look at Josh Manson
he finds the way he almost gets himself oh it hits
Manson right in the chest and gorv is a little bit
deep in his net there but he never really saw the
reaction he went to go catch it and then all of a
sudden it was back to kicks it back here's colon
the Tampa Bay Lightning flare put it in front
M there to knock it away Gregor's got to lean to
the dead and stopped by G have a rebound and mcmah
stopped in tight in the offensive zone so when you
can make a break it's mccave jumping on the loose
parck and watch as he put it to the outside he
lost control dream put it on the stick of Matthews
n's after it his stick lifted by drwam now set
deep and Matthews will get there first teams
back out tracking him Matthews put away stopped by
gorf off Marner back door what a pass by Matthews
here comes mckinon and R it and he Whi that wide
to the line and across it goes to marar he finds
Ronin a backand turned aside by Jones cycled
by McKinnon towards bruan but broken up there
by Riley he'll swallow up to Center Steels Morgan
Riley scores an Allstar goal for Morgan Riley oh
man you talk about some high event hockey just
great plays back on transition Colorado putting
some pressure on and Morgan Riley basically
does this himself everybody else is changing
a bouncing Puck on a great stick and then
just backand out I think giori has kind
of got frozen here thinking maybe Riley would
go back to his forehand instead just a little
hesitation and a flip up and over and walks
the handle down into the corner kept in by
Jord in front Holberg on the doorstep a couple
whacks another whack now star it's Timothy
Len in front and they continue on able to keep the
puck in as J down and in tight here A Bouncing pu
that twice looked like Gerard was going to be
able to clear and in for the point smart play
there by little you can see all the Avalanche
looking towards the net nobody looking behind
them and it's Len who sneaks in Riley wasl tday
Hit It Center Holberg a plus three and got an
assist added at the end of the first period it's
turned over inside the line W fromberg stopped
by gor with a huge stop as he goes absolute
rocket pass from Max doy comberg coms up high
and he's got his stick ready for this but it's
just a rocket that Jared bnar was able to take
advantage of to get the power play power play
with red move from 18th they're going to get
another one here a high sticking penalty it's
Loos in front scores they were trying to give
it away to get the whistle but drewan scores oh
boy now you've got another Power Play coming up
that that's a play you can't stop look at the
bodies in front of the net off of the draw oh
yeah The airon Stick of Camp gets up in the
face so down he goes now what a smart play to
just keep it alive C there I think was surprised
that this was coming through to him but he did a
great job look at drewan at the last second Just
Adjust and realize he's got an open shot away and
I know it's a split second decision that's now
four of the last five that have gone in against
this lead penalty killing in the last three games
Ran's got 10 goals on the year five in his last
six that pits in front and Jones with a big stop
on Ross Colton as he comes on to the ice neander
Matthews and Marner but now KNE Lander to the
v threw it in front just out of the reach of
McKinnon back door R in checked stick of kniv get
caught up Gerard shooting up Lake scores M ran to
the it's a one goal game I mentioned the crowd
kind of felt it too a really important stretch
and this Top Line you just got a sense that they
ratcheted it up another level McKinnon in the
neutral zone watch this early play this was a good
job of giving it to the outside tried to give and
go and the pass by druin unable to connect but
a good job of keeping the Pu no penalty there
Colorado looked like they were wanting one
instead ni picks up his stick ranin who was
calling for a call gets this fortuitous bounce a
block shot nice doesn't even know where it is and
it's ranin who off of his knees turns around
all of a sudden the pucks on his but K unable
to handle that lead keep it in here's deander
wide deander fired that short side stopped by
gor now up for Matthews lead some counter punch
here's nander putting it on goal rebound and Goram
got just enough of that is both teams's going
backwards he puts it towards the net now on
the rebound from a tough angle Riley up ahead
Doby spun around Colorado back on it and cago
shot hit traffic and goes to the quarter here's
Manson shooting cocko scores Andrew cocko has tied
it but clear they survived that but it's three
goals in a row that you get kind of a 20 bounce
here's cogliano getting it back to the point which
is a common theme that one gets deflected on the
Block and comes right back into his wheelhouse
you can see the reaction of Joan expecting that
one to come through instead it gets blocked this
shot right there gets blocked in a Rolling Puck
the ciano able to get it up and to the left
side of the net to tie this game short over
the line short handed and he wired that high
KNE Lander can't keep it in back the other way
Colton two on one with ran and scolling play by
Beno and they continue to battle for that loose
pacus inside the line H in here is lilligren yard
coat and it's stopped by Gori EV frook or maybe
blocked by jard and now McKinnon may get away
up ahead it goes here through a over the line
drops across mckinon stops shoots scores Nathan
McKinnon and the ledge and their first lead of the
night pressure at the other end had three
or four good chances to get it to the net
the Colorado aalan able to box out Duran
just drops it to rans in and this is one
with McKinnon showing great patience that
little stop up there forces the D Man Down
watch McKinnon here doesn't shoot so now mck is
slid away Mar's trying to get in the shooting
Lane and McKinnon with great patience Takes Two
Little Steps puts it right underneath the arm of
Here Comes Johansson up ahead with an open
net and off the post R Colton doesn't cash
and the Le still have life he can't believe
it looking Skyward had time looked like he
took his time to make sure here's Gibby
ranta back in and that knocked off the
stick to Porton again the finally get it and
point in the right direction Greger was offs
side the pass broken up by kimby Red though
Johansson across Second Chance Colton doesn't
miss 53 Colorado look skyward
leaps unable to get it in nice
play by Johansson not taking it himself
giving him another one first and 13 for
Ross Colton Johansson Kibby ranta at 1956 53
excuse me and this one's in the Box it's the